-Good evening, I'm Seth Myers.
This is "Late Night".
We hope you're doing well, and
now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden spoke last night
about the upcoming
midterm elections and said,
quote, "In our bones,
we know democracy is at risk."
And you know the president is
old when he gets his best intel
from his bones.
Ah, knee's acting up,
I feel a veto coming on.
President Biden urged voters
in his speech last night
to stand up for democracy and
said that Americans don't settle
political differences, quote,
"With a riot or a mob
or a bullet or a hammer."
We don't?
Because if not,
that's a weirdly specific list.
That's like if your wife asked
if you were cheating
and you said, "I don't even
think Rebecca's that sexy,
and I certainly wouldn't meet up
with her
at the Hotel Radisson Airport."
I put all the word
in a different order.
I wanted to see if it worked,
if you put them all
in a different word.
That's how you say it, right?
The Hotel Radisson Airport.
Alex -- he's our director --
can you just cut it up
and move all the words around
in post?
Problem solved. [ Laughs ]
In a new interview, Georgia
Senate candidate Herschel Walker
said that he has a better résumé
than Former President
Barack Obama.
Really? It's better than
Former President Barack Obama?
The only thing your résumé has
that his doesn't is typos.
CNN released a new poll
yesterday that suggests
Democrats may be facing
an enthusiasm problem
ahead of next week's
midterm elections,
which explains this here
sticker.
Former President Trump is
reportedly considering
the two-week stretch after
the midterm elections
as a window to formally announce
he's running for president
in 2024.
Oh, right before Thanksgiving?
Awesome.
Are you also gonna announce
that Aunt Lisa and her friend
aren't just roommates?
Elon Musk tweeted yesterday,
quote...
For instance, it could mean
you're the president.
SpaceX this week launched
its Falcon Heavy,
which is the most powerful
rocket in the world,
but I don't know how safe it is,
considering SpaceX is, I guess,
Elon Musk's third priority.
Who starts a space program
in their spare time?
NASCAR driver Ross Chastain
qualified
for a championship race
over the weekend
after performing
a wall-riding maneuver
that he claimed to have learned
from a Nintendo GameCube
video game as a child.
Even crazier, Denny Hamlin moved
into fifth place
after throwing a red shell
at the driver in front of him.
Two chefs in Boston recently set
a Guinness World Record
by assembling a sushi roll
that was over seven feet wide.
Now for the sad news.
[ Laughter ]
We realized the real problem
with that joke
is Shamu died like 20 years ago,
right?
[ Laughter ]
Don't eat other sushi.
And finally Dunkin' Donuts is
now offering its holiday menu
which includes a pancake
Wake-Up Wrap
that's filled with eggs,
American cheese,
and sausage or bacon.
The part they don't tell you is
where you'll wake up.
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
We got a great show
for you tonight.